[Music]
metas
shift in league of legends champion
picks come and go
but there's a champion that always seems
to weather the storm
it isn't because he's always the
strongest
it's because when it comes to showing
off how mechanically skilled you are
there's no champion like him
and once you've had a taste of that
freedom well
it's not easy to give it up and if you
want to prove that you belong beside
the best junglers in the world you have
to show
that you have a lease sin
is terrifying there goes the teleporter
gets the double kill peter has guardian
angel maybe he plays front line
how much can they really get played
through the turn
looks for it all he's got one how much
more can they get the stuns coming in
and it's stupid the big play with the
turn around from prey
turning it back in the chase the
resonating strike
and the ace goes and you never forget
being a lee sin god just ask insect you
bring it back eventually
[Music]
lee sin was unleashed unto the world on
april 1
2011. alongside the regular champion
spotlight trailer
riot games also released a funny reveal
for april fools
lee sin is a ranged melee tanky dps
assassin mage tank support jungler
he excels at everything but the blind
monk
wasn't a joke with the ability to move
huge distances
using both enemies and allies he
redefined what mobility in league meant
but lee's alt dragon's rage is really
what set him apart
a massive kick knocked enemy champions
back
and other enemies in the path were
knocked into the air
it was a playmaker's dream kicking a
vulnerable enemy
back into your team could turn the tide
instantly
these two factors meant that at least on
paper
there was the potential to seriously
outplay the opponent
on top of that he has a lot of tools
that are always going to work in the pro
scene the fact that you can
have such a large distance that you can
close onto the opponent
and then kick them backwards into your
team means no matter what
you're always going to have the
opportunity to have a viable team fight
in the game
and then his early game ganking is also
strong so he's got all those things kind
of going for him
but lee sin didn't make an incredible
splash the moment he was released
he was barely played at season 1 worlds
and was never banned
but by season 2 there were aggressive
junglers
trying to push the champion's limits
foremost among them
was moscow 5's diamond prox who became
known for early game aggression
especially counter-jungling rather than
play it safe on a tanky jungler and
spend his time dealing with
wards diamondprox brought the fight to
the enemy looks like the invictus may be
able to take their first dragon here
they have been three diamond plots
waiting on the wing
to get in there and smite this out who
will be able to grab their diamond
diamond plugs
grabs it out can they win the fight they
lost a lot of hp on the focus there
alex is on a rampage as he drops pdt
and it looks like they will be able to
melt a few members here
of invictus gaming diamond is still
alive somehow
puts on the shield can they get these
last two with a sliver of health and an
ace and the dragon steal when they lose
three
and a core part of that strategy was lee
sin's
early game dueling so basically arsenal
said you know
diamond diamond when he's playing good
on leasing he's like his queue's not a
skill it's just like a headshot
he just he will be on you and you'll be
dead at world season 2
he was one of only two players to play
lee sin
or have it banned against him but the
champion's most iconic play
would not be seen on the big stage until
may 2013 at all stars
and it was there that insects showed off
the combo
that would ultimately be named after him
could just be because he got a good
early start they're going with it but
it's definitely
definitely impactful for this game and
the fact is
coming out for giant and they're not
done just yet they're going to chase
down
diamond there is a natural galaxy that
through the wall the piltover peacemaker
not quite landing and diamond got a
speed away and the start of this fight
was just
so key when insect comes in behind
galaxy cues in wards back kicks in that
is so
hard to execute even though europe tried
to come would have made
really everyone sit on the rumble
ultimate they'd already lost their 80
carry and they burned all their cc
release account initiation so the rest
of korea just chased down here it's easy
to dismiss this play today
because it's considered something that
any competent lee sin player can pull
off
but that moment showed everyone that
even two years
after the champion's release pro players
were only
just scratching the surface and it
reinforced the idea that
for the mechanical jungler lee sin was
the ultimate test
a jungler could not be called truly
elite
if lee sin was not part of their arsenal
i always enjoy casting lee sin because
skill expression is very evident so if
someone knows exactly what they're doing
you can really see how good a player is
when they're playing lee sin because
he's so hard
he has so much play making potential and
the best players seem to always be
the best at him but while lee sin gave
junglers
a new kind of freedom league of legends
was changing
in the early years of league of legends
support players were forced into a very
vision-centric playstyle
that saw them blanket the map with wards
at the cost of their own item builds
this was a benefit to lee sin with wards
everywhere
there were options for hopping around
with safeguard but the season three
patch
made vision a team responsibility and
lee sin
players would have to figure out how to
get enough wards of their own the
default option
became the newly introduced sightstone
by the end of season 3 it was clear that
lee sin
was a dangerous weapon in the hands of
an expert
he went from being nearly ignored to
having a 63.5
pick ban rate at worlds and bengi the
jungler for 2013's eventual world
champions
sk telecom t1 dominated with him
piglet just chunking in there as pengy
want to move around the back here
shockwave actually gonna pull him in
magna here in all kinds of troubles he
lands the champ can they get across
blast from biggie lands the q then the
kill from faker
he would also achieve another milestone
becoming the first lee sin master
honored with his own world skin more
than ever
lee sin was the ultimate example of
skill expression
and as big names put on outstanding
shows with the champion
up-and-coming talent took notice and
then timed his dive here very
effectively it might not be over yet
pirate yeah we had that flash and then
comes gankos now
lulex is the one who gets hooked they
throw in the sapling flash away from
lulex going for him jankos wants to
finish him off he's going low but he
gets the kill
flashes takes the lantern the juke still
alive shock blast intercepted by bander
steve and nice play hanging out good
play here comes akron though the 4v5
from lmq will it be good enough facility
very low the q lands from lee sin they
don't chase down
big damage kicks back in the shutdown
now no they've got nowhere to go three
kills picked up ackerman
goes in for this fight but isn't going
to be enough
dandy getting this position behind oh i
think bang's in trouble there's a kick
they kick him in oh the death sentence
bada nearly comes in there's the box
and mvp ozone it's going to absolutely
slaughter senex last goodbye bang
lee sin's rise meant that tons of
players were eager to try their own hand
at the champion
casual players undaunted by the
complexity
and perhaps inspired by the pros began
to lock in the blind monk
even if their team would rather they
didn't and those players
inability to resist hitting q a second
time
earned their play a name lee syndrome
i hit the queue the queue must be going
in on okay that the full
chart for my logic is gonna be is enemy
in range if yes
press q if not don't press q did enemy
get hit
yes press q again no revert back to
phase one of the full chart
very simple very easy to remember while
lee sin
hadn't changed a lot from release the
jungle itself had
in late 2015 another huge shift
would help the champion's popularity the
revamp of jungle items
that included tracker's knife a jungle
specific item that
also gave wards was maybe the biggest
buff that lee sin had received
since his release but with tracker's
knife in the game
and junglers hungry to prove their
mechanical excellence
it was a golden age for lee sin at
worlds 2016
he was tied for highest jungle presence
with olaf
and for good reason running out of
health he gets shot down as well but
prey
does he find the targets peanut has
guardian angel maybe he plays front
line how much can they really get played
through the connection
he's got one what else can he get it's
gonna be blake in his sights
he's coming back faker's low how much
more can they get the studs coming in
and it's stupid the big play
with the turn around from prey turning
it back in the chase
the resonating strike and the ace goes
through for peanut
and now a new generation of junglers who
had watched players innovate in the
game's early days
wanted to prove that they had the
mechanics to compete
one such jungler was broxah who spent
2016
trying to make his way into the eu lcs
until that comes back up you have to be
so much more safe
with your realm you can't afford to get
yourself in a bad spot speaking of bad
spots
ghost is going to be used brock's this
right after him though there's the
insect coming on through
and that is a kill for nisky fanatic
pick up their hat
well i've always been really really
attracted by really good early game
champions really good skirmishers with
um like that really depend a lot on
having really good mechanics
um and in the first place i was a
and at least one trick and then at one
point i was like holy
like lee looks so fun i have to learn
this champion and then
ever since then i think that was like
four years ago i've just been loving lee
you have so much
potential to make big plays he's just a
really good skirmisher and
he's pretty much everything i like as a
jungler and i just really love the
champion
by spring 2017 broxah's flashy lee sin
play
was turning heads in the eu lcs the
champion had been out for five years
and during that time had seen a number
of tweaks
but a shift in the jungle meta ended up
nerfing lee sin
harder than any balance change would
have by worlds 2017
the infamous ardent sensor meta was in
full force
and for the jungle that meant
prioritizing scaling champions like
sejuani and jarvan
but will they play ad
carry protect him art sensor
khan on a tank i love the fact that
they're doing what g2 did and saying ah
that's banter janna first of all and
maybe even the lula
to get rid of some of these art sensor
supports
if lee sin mains were hoping for a
change that would make the champion
more viable in 2018 they ended up
disappointed
because the core of modern lee sin
builds tracker's knife
was removed in patch 8.4 the idea
wasn't to target lee sin it was to
reduce vision
generally in the hopes of making the
game less predictable
but since sightstone had also been
removed it left lee sin
in a terrible place now with
no cheap access towards it seemed like
the art of playing lee sin
was on the verge of extinction
in 2018 in every major region
lee sin was barely played before worlds
but it was clear that the game's best
hadn't forgotten that he existed
i'm fascinated as to where orange you go
with this because you definitely don't
want to pick the trundle
olaf could be an option but will he go
potential staple pick of his
and this is what we wanted him to bring
back yesterday
and you never forget being a lee sin god
just ask insect you bring it back
eventually
it's going to be great to see and at
worlds 2018
as fanatic went deep into the tournament
broxah reminded everyone
that lee sin was more than just another
champion
he was a secret discipline one that
broxah nurtured
even after tracker's knife was gone and
he unleashed it
on the biggest stage in league of
legends goes
all the way under the tower
he didn't follow it through yeah
first blood for brox's lee sin now he's
gonna get away
takes the hammer to the face from under
continued to running looking at the mini
map hilly sack
he's coming up there's a problem and
this coming from the side a cosmic
finding
is body block oh my god the shield and
then everything survives
broxah gets down alive now hill is
saying the target rius teleported him
for the fight
i am speechless how fanatic did that
well they're going to try for another
one though and this one body slam stops
the cue
here comes valen as well 2v1 proxima may
have been off more than he can chew the
health part running down
the kick the second get out that was
gorgeous
and there's another one coming as jackie
love also falls
fanatic win the skirmish and broxah is
an absolute
monster for fnatic this game even though
they ultimately lost to ig
fnatic were the first western team to
reach grand finals
at worlds since season one and brox's
ability to play lee sin
was a big part of that it was a reminder
that even when the blind monk seemed
overshadowed
he was always waiting to unleash the
dragon
yeah so try to figure out why lee sin
always remains viable
one of the most simple things about it
is almost every jungler who's made it to
pro
has put in a ton of games on me sin
because he's so
fun and he has so much skill expression
so if you're a good player
you probably like playing lee sin and
you put a bunch of games into him so you
think you can make him work
in 2011 lee sin's mobility was nearly
unthinkable
it gave junglers the most freedom they'd
ever had to outplay opponents
and show their mechanical prowess but
after years of power creep
many newer champions in league have
incredible mobility
despite that lee sin is still around
and it's because junglers today still
know
that he's the ultimate test of their
ability junglers like sofm
have stayed true to the blind monk and
have even brought
new build ideas to the table takes to
the skies to dodge the arrow but here's
that's authem he's got the flash he's
got himself a chilling smite but doesn't
quite land it clear up that's the first
target tries to deliver him through
even flandre gets in on the action so fm
with a ward hop smite
finally locks it down seven to
one for snake king sofm the 2019 world
champion
tian was featured as lee sin in the 2020
world's music video
a nod to his own incredible performances
with the champion
the silver is terrifying there goes the
teleporter
[Music]
gets the double kill and when the chips
were down in the world's 2020
quarterfinals
karsa equipped tian's fpx lee sin skin
and turned the tide for his team here
comes casa as well as dracula from the
mid lane what can jackie love do
with a double box he's jumping on a
purple he's got the damage done whipper
gets a knock up hillerson follows up
can't find it though
defensive flash away jacqueline
continues to check
the resonating strike from corsa
cannot find the kill jackie off stays
alive the shielding
from karma does it but fanatic get out
and the cycle
continues masters inspired new
students while we may never again see a
meta dominated by the champion
you can bet that a new generation of
junglers will keep their pocket lease in
well honed and whether you think they're
gods
uh gillius gillius king of lee sin a sin
to godhood and grant me this win or
lee sinners i don't i'm just so their
comp looks so confusing
the evil geniuses it's just so wrong
about that right
it is there's no language
with one another oh who's that even a
blind monk can see that lee sin
isn't going anywhere failure has not
stopped me before
it will not now
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages